we discussed today which files and which
issues we should focus on in the
remaining month including the proposals
made by president Juncker in his State
of the Union speech and we especially
welcomed the efforts for a closer
partnership to African completing the
single market strengthening the role of
the European Union as a global player
and the efforts on implementing a
digital text another topic was the
multi-annual financial framework and the
undergoing discussions towards this
important issue
building up on the work of the Bulgarian
president team and the guidance provided
by the European Council in June the
presidency has pushed for progress on
this complex file and we will continue
to do so just to underline that we've
had a good discussion about our logistic
problem I'm very grateful to the
Austrian presidency and I have to say
the Commission is in full agreement with
the priorities set by the Austrian
presidency which are also strongly
supported in the council at the end of
the day before the European elections
European citizens will be interested in
our results it's Europe and Europe has
to deliver the issue you're probably
waiting me to comment upon is the second
hearing we've had today on the issue of
the rule of law in Poland I don't have
much good news for you but between the
first and second hearing the
Commission's concerns and worries have
increased I think the situation in
Poland has not improved the reactions
the Commission has received from the
Polish government do not offer any
openings in terms of compliance with
what the Commission had put on the table